so if anyone thought that covid was
behind us the last few weeks and some
new numbers tell a very different story
daily covered numbers about 26 percent
from the previous week are up and
according to the centers for disease
control and prevention about one third
of americans now live in high risk areas
but there's also a new weapon to help
children battle covid cbs medical
contributor dr david agus is with us
this morning for more let's start before
we get to the kids with those higher
transmission numbers we're seeing them
up in certain areas since last week
what's that sort of indication as to
what may be ahead and are masks still
the best way to prevent that spread well
dana numbers obviously are going up
across the country and given that
there's less testing you have to take
those numbers almost with a grain of
salt they are dramatically higher we are
at a significant rush of cases all
around the country with this new omicron
variant and i think that's important at
the same time hospitalizations are going
up but not that much which is a good
sign and that reflects the immunity and
the vaccines that have been working
right and again is it masking is that
still the best option no question about
it you go to a crowded place you should
wear a mask period it's not going to be
a masks mandate but please care about
others we're one community where that
mass stops spread to others it's a
no-brainer
where you say we're not going back into
lockdown and that's an important part of
this right we're not what more than two
years you've got that look in your face
we're not going back i mean because i
remember very clearly when you first
came on when you said the world is
changing is going to change two years
ago and some of us were like come on and
it did it has for
two years plus so what stage do you
think we are at in the pandemic right
now
you know we're going to live with the
virus right we're going to accept that
we're all gonna get it there's going to
be every six months cadence you're gonna
stay home from work for seven to ten
days when you get the virus if we keep
our vaccines and our boosters up our
immunity up it's gonna be very mild and
it's not gonna be a big issue and the
people who are high risk will take pills
um or a shot that will block the virus
so they won't be hospitalized and so
this is a new
normal and the new normal is living with
rather than hiding from the virus and dr
agus what about paxylvid do you
recommend that anyone infected with
covid take it but are there any risks
involved in that so paxylvid is a
remarkable drug you know the virus is
not alive it gets into our cell and uses
our machinery to divide and this blocks
that
the good of paxilvid is it decreases
hospitalization by 90 plus percent it's
pretty dramatic the bad of pax levitt
now is that interacts with a lot of
medicines you got to make sure that
nothing your own interacts with it and
in some people when they stop taking it
a few days later you get a surge in the
virus again mild but it's real and
you're infectious again and it probably
means we haven't done the right dose or
we need a longer course we're still
learning how to use it but it is a very
good drug parents are still waiting for
some good news when it comes to
vaccinations for kids under five but
right now kids five to eleven pfizer has
had their shot recommended for a booster
do you recommend that for kids it's kind
of again a no-brainer in that regard you
get a dramatic increase in immunity and
the virus is changing it's not that the
vaccines aren't working well the virus
is changing right so get that increased
immunity keep your child protected and
then hopefully in mid-june the younger
will be a vaccine for them now this is
the part where you don't tell us we're
going to go into a new lockdown please
for two years and the world is going to
change forever when i ask you about
monkey pox
and what this means he's got a serious
voice and i'm like i've got it again
because i'm prepared now for what you
might say we're ready to walk off the
set if you say our livestream is a
cousin of smallpox it's spread by rats
and then you know goes to humans and
normally it's not that infectious like
smallpox is but it's got a significant
mortality rate there's been 20 cases in
the uk there's a case in boston it looks
like there's a case here in new york now
so there's probably a new version that
is spreading it does not seem to be a
major issue the smallpox vaccine does
protect against it we stopped using it
in the 70s but there is a supply of it
so i think it's something we're watching
it's not something that i'm majorly
concerned with at the present time which
is going to probably get me in trouble
but i think we have to see you know we
have treatments for it also right but i
think we just have to be aware of it and
you know we'll get more data from the
cdc and other countries over the next
couple weeks literally the first case
was just sequence so we're going to
learn more as we go dr david agus thank
you very much for joining us